how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
relating to Marvel I hope everyone's
being safe out there today we have some
awesome venom to news so in a couple of
videos that I did this week I said that
we can expect the venom to trailer
pretty soon there's a lot that's
starting to come out about venom 2 and
according to a report from deadline Andy
Serkis the director of venom 2 said that
everything is still on track for their
October 2nd release date and deadline
says that we can expect a trailer as
early on as this week and now we have
even more news about the trailer the
corona virus has taken its toll on a few
Marvel movies already Morbius has been
pushed back and of course unfortunately
Black Widow has been pushed back as well
and venom 2 right now is our only hope
and it looks like we are indeed getting
this trailer soon according to a pretty
reliable source Twitter account emit
said Hari said I heard that a teaser
trailer for venom 2 has reached the
various Sony international markets under
the localization process that means it's
online debut is on the cards unless
something bad happens this Twitter
account has accurately leaked trailer
information in the past from
localization sources and according to
this account the teaser trailer is
complete and it has reached various Sony
international markets under the
localization process and basically what
this means when a trailer is being
localized it usually arrives pretty soon
after that typically no longer than a
couple of weeks but since we also have a
report from deadline that said we can
expect a trailer pretty soon I imagine
it won't probably take two weeks now
again due to the corona virus that can
affect many different things in many
different aspects of things being
released but again according to the
director of venom 2 everything is still
on track the filming has been completed
the editing process has begun and the
teaser trailer is most likely underway
which again according to this Twitter
account
it is so after this report and the
report from deadline we can definitely
expect to see the venom 2 trailer is
soon however the big question now is are
we actually going to see carnage in the
venom 2 teaser trailer if you recall the
original teaser trailer for venom barely
showed the Venom symbiote most of the
footage was just of Eddie Brock and
everybody else not the actual symbiotes
so do you think we see carnage in the
actual teaser trailer let me know
you think in the comments down below
leave a like if you're excited for venom
to and carnage and don't forget to
subscribe and notifications turned on to
stay up to date on everything relating
to venom and of course all things Marvel
and I'm still given away an Xbox one or
ps4 at five hundred and fifty thousand
subscribers as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof